residential buildings on fire in
hospital Northwest of Kiev
nearby in the town of irpin dramatic
scenes and heavy shelling by the Russian
army
civilians trying to help the wounded in
the absence of medical workers
there was also heavy damage here at the
jitomi type plant
and destruction in the cities of
Charleston and ovrock in the jitomi
region in Northern Ukraine according to
State media
in his latest statement president volodo
mirzelensky said Russian shelling has
destroyed the average shift Venezia
International Airport he warned Russia
is preparing to bomb the historic South
Eastern port city of Odessa
the city has more than a million people
including Bulgarian and Jewish
minorities
they are planning to bombard Odessa the
Russians always used to come to Odessa
and they felt only warmth only sincerity
in Odessa and now bombs are coming
against Odessa artillery missiles this
is going to be a war crime a historic
crime
but the Russian army is talking only
about military targets it says it has
destroyed
2203 military facilities in Ukraine
during what it calls a special operation
I mean the offensive continues to stoke
popular anger in Ukraine especially in
the besieged southeastern region
there was hope thousands could Escape
From the besieged City of mariopom in
the Southeast but the evacuation was
called off after both sides claimed
these five violations many other
ukrainians have escaped the Russian
bombardment for neighboring countries
unhcr says the number of refugees has
now passed 1.5 million making it the
largest Exodus in Europe since World War
II Muhammad Al Jazeera
well let's take a closer look at Odessa
which is the third largest city in
Ukraine it's often known as the pearl of
the Black Sea but it's also a
significant port for The Wider region
with strategic pipelines oil and
chemical processing facilities as well
as major transport hubs if Russia
manages to take the city it would cut
off Ukraine's access to the Black Sea
I'll just see there is more from Odessa
hi there
we've been hearing sirens in Odessa here
where we stand the Ukrainian Army says
they've downed a Russian warplane this
comes after a statement made by the
governor of Odessa who said that all the
air defenses have been put into action
along the Black Sea Coast these
statements imply that a new batch of
missiles and aircraft have been received
by the Ukrainian Army in the city at the
same time these statements may also
explain president zielinski's warning
that Russia May strike Odessa using
warplanes zielinski said that Odessa has
been warmly welcoming Russian tourists
for years but now it's come under
Russian bombardment he also said if
Russia bombards the city it will be a
historical crime and a war crime
Odessa is the heart of tourism in
Ukraine it receives millions of tourists
annually the majority of whom are
Russians it's also important to note
that the center of the city has not come
under attack so far it's only the
outskirts of the city that have been
targeted
the Northwestern city which you told me
it has also been hit by heavy shelling
more than a dozen buildings some of them
residential have been destroyed in
recent days Steve vason has more from
well this is just a very ordinary
residential area in shotomier and this
is how an airstrike or the impact of an
airstrike looks like a Russian airstrike
was done here on Friday a missile hit
this area
this house there was a young woman 28
years old she died here we just spoke to
her father in that house over there you
see some people on the roof three
children got severely injured ended up
in hospital the youngest was three years
old this is a pure residential area it's
not very far from an air base or
military base I have to say the military
base is like hundreds of meters that way
and it's very hard for these residents
to understand what was actually the
purpose of this strike was it really the
military base or
was that was this the target so there's
a lot of anger here in this area because
it's a it's a third residential area
that I've seen struck here in jotomia
since I've arrived here uh there was
another one over there also in the
vicinity of the military base but not
quite there also residential area lots
of shops destroyed and people are here
just picking through the rubble they're
still like completely in shock lots of
emotions heartbreaking stories people
really completely don't understand why
this area was hit people have nowhere to
go they say because this is an unsafe
area lots of people have left they don't
know where to go and they're just
picking up the pieces trying to find
something that is still valuable that
they can that they can keep but the
anger here is unbelievable the people
are really defiant people who are still
here say we're not going anywhere and if
the Russians come we will fight them
personally